好 谢谢大家时间啊
然后最近上星期市场
其实主要被geopolitical issues在那里影响
就是美国和伊朗的冲突嘛
美国和以色列和伊朗的冲突
然后那个我说一下最近几个
战争还是那么我最大的一个风险
我说一下最近市场可能有一些其他的这个风险在
然后后面的其实很大的动向呢
其实跟美国或者是伊朗的政策相关很大
那么我自己点简单点评一下
也引用一下那个狗们或者是几个
他们一些顾问的一些意见吧
那么毕竟我不是一个战争经济学的专家
但是我说一下它就是我的看法
然后上周市场其实波动很大的是利率
这个不光是美国的利率
其实在欧洲欧阳的利率
英邦利率波动都很大
也就是美国和以色列打了伊朗之后
那个上周伊朗开始对那个海峡进行封锁
或者它去骚扰海峡上面传吧
那导致其实周一的时候油价涨了很多
周一油价涨的其实在周四周五的时候
油价就已经开始上涨
然后油价的上涨的导致前端去压住BOE
就是英国洋行去cut的这些trade全部 collapse
全部崩溃
那这一次的利率的波动在美国
因为我这个时尚已经收到没有放一月份以来
其实时间期利率或者是美国整体利率
这个这样幅度的波动在一月份时候发生过一次
这一次发生和一月份的其实风险的状态是不太一样的
但是两次波动都很大了
一月份的时候更多的是日本的央行
然后日本央行大家觉得它可能偏软弱
然后日本的政府要去花很多钱
就是日本政府要做capital expenditure
要做很大的fitical expenditure
然后因为它做fitical expenditure
导致长端利率 collapse
长端利率 duration risk collapse
然后侧面引发了欧洲的利率和美国利率的问题
那当时其实还是也停留在一个经济层面
也就是说这件事情只要是停在经济层面
它是完全可供的
就包括我们说关税
关税有一点就是关税战
虽然说它也是一个战
但是它毕竟是个经济战
所以这件事情就是一旦川普开始taco了
它还是可控的
所以当时我没有对利率觉得风险往上的风险特别特别大
那个4.2的时候我觉得就是基本上
美元10年级率到4.2就到头了
然后因为最终我们不会认为有一个
特别负责任的货币政策
出现在不负责任的财政政策中间
包括日本也是这样
包括美国也是这样
所以这还是可测的
那这一次其实它的setup是一个stafflation
就是会不会因为油价狂涨
因为油价涨了很多
油价昨天当然晚上又跌回去了
但是盘中的时候
昨天亚洲时间是涨得很高的
涨到115
那会不会因为油价涨的特别多以后
导致美国通胀
然后影响廉储降息
或者是导致廉储变
说深吸吧
我觉得不太可能
现在美国看的CPI的这个指标和过去
其实是不一样的
就是说70年代看CPI
我们后来看的都是核心CPI
core CPI
然后现在看的是core PCE
对吧
core PCE
你说要从油价传导到core PCE
会不会会的
但是不会短期
就是不是在一个星期两星期油价
你不管涨到300 500
这几个星期里面
它只能让你加油价钱变高
但是PCE里面的service shadow
shadow就是那个房租
然后人员的产版这些东西
包括产品都涨不上去的
你可以看到就举个例子
你就看美国去加了关税了
对中国加关税
那中国进口商品
直接进入CPI的核心CPI的
或者核心PCE的产品里面
就是它一部分是产品
一部分是服务
一部分是房租
那你进到产品里面
但是对PCE的影响
也没有你们想象那么大
就是它也是marginal
就影响可能去年零点几个点
零点二零点五个点
然后你油价的上升
会让能源价格上升
带动其他价格上升
但是这个是需要油价长期
维持在一个高位
然后才会慢慢传导到前端去
那本质上对于经济的影响
我觉得基本面影响是不影响的
就是见面不影响
就是它的整个一年为期
更长周期里面
它的状态是经济增长比较
相对来说比较良性
然后通胀偏disinflation
就是disinflation通胀偏向于变弱
然后失业率
就是通胀的失业是更加相关
失业率相对来说不是很好看
这个可能是美国经济的基本的一个setup
但是这个账路打很长时间
或者是拖很长时间
那就不太好讲
打仗本身要花钱
而且打仗会有一些各方面的影响
这个是我们对基本面的看法
但是市场短期交易不是这样子
市场短期交易是让
比如说我们叫beflattening
就是在短端的利率上升的更快
然后快过长端
然后开始定价stafflation
就是因为市场紧张的情绪会一下子很紧张
在利率前面的话就是
虽然长端也在涨
但是短端定价可能更加快一点
然后那个
在利率上升的时候
其实还有一些风险
就是其实在上周的时候
今天我不知道亚洲时间会怎么样
但是在星期的时候
特别在星期的时候
U.S.到了到em currency
就是U.S.到了到发展中国家
到比方说韩语院
到拉丁的那些国家
这些carotree cash in one
就是不光你会看到有
到了em的carotree
然后这些钱是到美国去的
但是也是有
到了em的carotree
然后这些钱是带动em的这些市场
就是给em市场数学的
这些carotree在很关
所以利率会导致很多de-risk
就是de-risk就是我们叫去港感
会导致很多的去港感
de-leverage de-risk
然后会有很多的其他的影响
所以我觉得更加关注利率
因为这个东西在短期里面
它是并不是受到长期基本面影响
它很多程度上就受到你
战争的进程是怎么样
然后这个伊朗反馈是怎么样的
比方说周末时候
伊朗把哈美利尼的儿子选上去了
那么哈美利尼其实上周就说这件事情
那个大家其实有一个看法认为
共和国会对RGC控制的
对伊朗控制还是很强的
然后可能会跟美国就是
可能会更贬任
更加强硬吧
所以对油价的话
它影响就是很负面
然后对于利率也是一样
因为油价的上涨
它的传递是从各方面
就油价上涨传递到利率
然后同时的话传递到股市
其实从利率信贷市场
也会传递到股市上面去
所以这个就是我们认为的
现在市场上最大的一个风险
也最不可测
那周一的时候
股市有很大程度的反弹
这个是因为特朗普在
好像是在说盘前
我刚才说盘前的时候
说基本上表示这个战争
差不多要完成了这个意思
但是呢
我引用几个就是
Kohen 就是沟门有一个叫做
President Global Fair
就是全球事务的一个主席吧
他原来是那个
他原来是民主党政府的时候的
那个希拉里的顾问
那是这么一个人
所以他原来是制定中东政策
就他对于
就我引用一下他
因为我毕竟不是战争经济学的专家
就我引用一下他对于伊朗事情的看法
就是伊朗这个国家呢
他是神圈政府
其实他一直防备着
以色列有可能对他进行斩首行为
所以在哈密的意思之前
他有很多的备案
就是这个备案呢
就是决定了如果我们收到袭击
然后那个最高领导人
没有办法发出指示
那么每一个军头下面
每一个RGC的军头
或者是每一个部门
应该执行什么样的任务
然后去比方说去放导弹去打谁
战争后就开打以后
没多长时间
他不是把周边国家都打了个遍
有有美国军事基地的人
或者是跟美国关系密切的
都打了一个遍
甚至他把挨撒白疆这种
和土耳其省自己的兄弟国家
也都打
这就说明了一个问题
就是他现在是一个
decentralized government
就是做那个剧中心化的政府
这剧中心化政府
就是有一群军头
RGC的军头一起把持
甚至现在那个被选上去
新的人被选上去
就哈密的一打就被选上去
他本身在神学领域
他不是
他不是那个
他们叫什么
那个神学的他们叫
他们不是他们神学领袖
就他在神学里面的这个地位
并不是很高
然后同时的话
他在军中的其实也也
也没有什么地位
就是他不是阿尔陶利
变成了一个最高领袖
叫阿雅陀
阿尔陶利
就是那个相当于是
他神学里面最高领袖
神学里面的最高的地位的人
就是说他不是阿尔陶利
然后变成了最高领袖
其实他很大程度上是受到
RGC就是共和国卫队的影响
共和国卫队和
和那个哈密尼和他老爸
本身是一个政治联盟
也就是哈密尼本身也不是阿尔陶利
然后他能够获得权力
他必须要养大这个他的这个军队
那边就相当于是他
他的那个共和国队是他的军队
然后给共和国队很多的
政治上的经济上的就钱上的
或者是装备上的这些优先权
所以他国内本身那个矛盾就很大了
这一次其实开战的更就从政治上
其实是帮到了共和国卫队
因为共和国卫队和哈密尼绑定太深
哈密尼在年初的时候
伊朗国内发生了很多的经济危机
90个9千万人的国家
有500万人上街游行
就是有500万人在在反对他
然后镇压导致了几万人的死亡
那么这个过程中间
哈密尼是本身是要被定在历史事务处上
那么他跟IRGC的
就是共和国卫队之间的这个紧密的关系
其实导致了共和国卫队
也要被定在历史事务处上
就是他们全部要完蛋
时间问题
但问题是美国打了一脑
而且让他驯到了
可是让那个哈密尼直接被打死 驯到了
所以就变成了一个本身是对内国内的一个矛盾很大
现在变成了对外的矛盾
使得对外矛盾压过的国内的矛盾
真正帮到的是没有被诈死那些IRGC的领导人
而且这些领导人其实出于他们最大的英传
所以他们最好的这个出发点
不是要把国家经济搞好
或者跟美国购合
或者是接受美国的条款
而是抗争到底
就是可以把国难
就是国家的后面可能在经济上面临的这些问题
全部挂到美国人头上去
所以这个是大概率的
就是这个是很有可能的事件
而且你要去推翻
就是因为IRGC在伊朗内部的控制能力上很强的
所以你要去推翻IRGC的统治
让快IRGC和神圈政府联合的神棍统治
难度也很大
就这个
也上周那个Kohai就讲过这个问题
就是认为美国如果要去把颠覆掉他的这个政权跟颠
颠覆掉他的政权是非常非常困难
而且新的政权在不管是他推举的是
还没那一大儿子还是他们是谁
但是上台的人呢
出于自己的最大的利益考量
就不是国家利益和个人和集团的利益是不同的
就是出于自己集团利益最大的考量
是要跟美国强行到底的
所以我觉得周一的时候美国当然了那个Trump
美国方面这样的表态
美国方面这样的表态呢
其实让市场大规模反弹
就是那个S&P业盘的时候
可能是跌了百分之二年去
NASDAQ跌到205
然后最后手盘是上涨
然后这个事情我个人感觉
就说战争的风险还是非常大
这个是说我们那么one risk
不好意思
那个有点感冒
然后呢
上一周
Position上来说
我认为风险还是就非常还是比较差的
Hedge Fund在整个1月份的时候
都是整8月份的时候都是在卖出
也就是我们看到整个Hedge Fund卖出
也就是通过卖出ETF
然后ETF的交易量到了
一个历史稿尾就变得非常大
然后Hedge Fund偷窜变空
所以我们会认为
就说现在机构上做空的做空
或者是看空头的相对来说
更多一点
就是更加坚决一点
那么我为什么说Position上还是风险很大
就这个抛开这个战争的因素
如果说真的不大
然后那个伊朗也不追追打美国
或者是两个人就互相之间牺牲凝人
这件事情倒没有发生过
然后伊朗继续反美
然后美国继续就美国继续对伊朗这个态度
但是伊朗继续反美
然后大家实际如果就这样过去了结束
那么市场是应该反弹到
比较说六千六千九
然后到七千之间
但是在六千九到七千七千左右吧
还是有很强的尬马屋
就是我们说在上面麦奥区的人还剩很多
所以他要在冲破上面需要搭连的资金的堆积
需要往下降导致CTA重新进去建仓
然后买更多
就比方说CTA走上面那个路径
下面是CTA
以下面一个星期不同的情况的这个织仓
你要让它往上长两个房产
然后把它重新加弹来买上去
然后回到这个上面
其实上下对称的难度不太一样
我讲的就是
但是往下的难度就没有那么大
就是那个
其实CTA分三种
其实CTA你可以认为就是趋势更重
就是它长的时候就这样
跌的时候就跟跌
要不就清算
就做红对吧
然后因为美股其实横盘了很久了
就横盘了几个月
所以在现在这个价位里面
如果是大概在六千六到六千七之间
六千七左右
六千七百多
六千七百出头
六千七百五的时候
那个short term CTA会
就短期的CTA会被flip
所以认为这个市场在下跌的趋势
然后在六千六百五
六六五左右
就是这个水平
六千六到六千七之间
那个迷连城中期的CTA会被flip
就是它会它会被变换头寸
所以当它变换头寸的时候
就是它会变成很大量的卖出
如果
就说我们现在看CTA
这个是SNP的CTA
SNP的CTA在flat平仓平的情况下
要卖出21个别领
卖出了大白11
这个规模是很大的
然后你要让它不卖出
就必须要上涨
就是要维持在昨天那个收盘价
甚至要继续往上涨
那么就可以走这个路径
就是走那个往上走路径
就变成买路了
但是正常如果只要flat
它就是往下
所以这一座风险
就是我们认为
我认为就是说
上下稍微有点不大对称
就是上下的风险在短期里面
就还是很大的
为什么有那么大的
就是昨天那种买盘呢
其实本质上美股的估值很便宜
就是你们要是比较长期的
去持有这个东西
我觉得确实是没有什么问题
你说像英伟达这种
就是在明年Forward的预期
可能12倍13倍批
就是你可以看看国内那些公司
在明年预期12倍13倍批的
然后是不是有英伟达这种
比方说今年80%吧
明年可能50%左右的增长有吗
然后就估值上来说
美股的估值
包括高科技公司的估值
它其实引力带动
就是还是可以
包括你像微软这种公司
其实到22倍批
然后现在估值
跟去年4月份
跌到底的时候差不多
但是现在市场短期的position setup
是很panic的
是很恐惧的
就是这个是CTA要卖出
就几方面CTA卖出机构做空
然后top of book order
现在是寒地的
top of book order
就我上几周也讲过这问题
就是1月份到现在
这个position很差的这个position
就是状态倉位的状态
延续到到现在
然后这个星期看到的
其实是比当时1月份更加差
那个top of book order
大概在今年1月份时候的
四分之一到五分之一的时候
就是你可以看
现在在五个面列
然后那个时候在二十五个面列
那个是什么意思呢
就是我现在在盘口
最近的盘口的卦单
然后这个卦单量比1月份
或者是比正常时间要少一半
然后结合
你想市场CT要卖出去
那你接盘的人
或者不管满上满下
都是要接盘的人
这个卦单的人变少了
做市场卦单变少了
然后那个市场在跌的时候
卖盘会变多
然后这个本身就会变成一个
往下很大的风险
就冲击的风险
就这种下跌呢
一般并不是说
我持续的就是说
整个固执性的clubs
会进入一个雄市
而是说他在调整的时候会很快
就如果他要往下调整很快
然后呢他要往上涨
他Gama是负的
现在Dele Gama已经变负的
所以为什么他会涨跌很快
就是Dele Gama是负的时候
那个买的时候
涨的时候他就买吗
跌的时候他就买
然后top of book order又少
所以他一旦一天一个情绪好
他就立马反转
涨很快
然后一个情绪不好
他就跌很凶
但是Gama是不对称的
就是当他你这个我这边没有显示
现在Dele Book Gama
Dele Book Gama代表Dele会干什么事情
他现在跌的时候
从现在开始有可能会卖空
但是他的Gama是会变化的
就是等你往下跌下去以后
往上涨的时候Gama会变正
也就是你你涨到比方说六千九七千的时候
他的对冲头存是做空的
但是往下跌的时候
他Gama会变了负的更厉害
大概在什么时候会变加速呢
在六千五
就是如果是跌到六千五的话
那个Shorten Gama是会变得负的非常严重
然后会有大量的卖盘出来
就是就Nectar Gama大量的卖盘
所以你想在六千七六千六
六千六到六千七
然后他有一个ZTA Flip
然后在六千五有个巨大的Short Gama
也就是如果你有机会
就这个很难打穿到这位置
就是毕竟故事定马
然后也有很多的那个散户卖盘
但是在往下百分之十的地方
有买了一个很大的雷
就是现在这个市场的状态就是这样
他不到百分之十吧
现在六千六千
现在六千七吧
那往下百分之五
百分之五到百分之六千五
对没到百分之五
就是现在六千六千八的话
往下大概三百个点
买了一个很大的雷
这个雷是可以确得让你往下一下子跌很多
所以如果说有调整的话
现在我不是说
他一定从固执上调整
因为美股从固执上来说并不贵
特别是很多科技公司
然后也杀过一轮
但是主要的是从仓位上来讲
他的就是往下如果要调整的仓位
往下的时候
仓位上是相对来说是比较危险
就这个危险的情况在
是结合了Gama Position
结合了CTA
然后同时结合了
现在手上的那个就是淘宝不高的
在一个阵矮
或当然机构在左口
当然在一个正常情况下
你虽然下面有个百分之五的雷
你说S&P的指数能不能跌下去
大概率也不会
但是现在毕竟不是一个正常情况
现在是在打仗
然后那个昨天的情绪缓和了
就是大家觉得修占了情绪缓和了
但是伊朗这个打仗
这个事情毕竟不是单边的
那不是美国和以色列单边的
这个是双边的
就是你是不是真正会停止骚扰
就是伊朗要拖着这个事情做很强硬
其实成本没有那么高
他并不需要打中你的船
他可能也打不中船
他现在也没有导弹
就是他的他的导弹
只需要导弹发射发射架
发出去5分钟就被美国人炸掉
所以他可能不一定有导弹库存
至少没有发射架
没有投射能力
他的无人机
那个夜市就是工厂被炸掉
然后发射
只要发射就可能被攻击
所以他未必有很强的真正的威胁
就是攻击打打伤害的能力了
他的这个弹药射出去的量
每天就是在减半这种速度下降
现在基本上你已经没有看到
他有能力再去攻击
比方说弹道导弹去攻击以色列温土了
但是他可以继续在海峡里面骚扰你
然后让那个传的
就是传的那个保险价格往上升
现在美国那边是出了等于直接担保这个
就相当于是给那个通行的传给保险了
然后同时的话去那个护航
但是这个非常久之间
他如果一直在那里骚扰你
市场又会进入另外一种定价状态
就这个仗好像打不完一样
就或者是别人产着你打价的打价的
不打价就错了
打仗的事情毕竟是两头的
他不是单边的
所以我们之前在讨论的他口
包括关税展
那个包括其实
创传内部的各种事情
他这个政府
就是他执政的中间经常会他口
他口以后市场就一下子就反弹
然后觉得一切好像没有发生过一样
经常这个样子
去年四月份就这样对吧
但是我们说的风险是
热战毕竟不是冷战
就是不仅不是经济战
热战是有失控的风险
一战的时候
没有一个国家就特别像德国
没有一个国家真的想打仗
大家都想把这些事情压下去
最后就失控
所以中间会有个确定性
而且这个不确定性半水的市场的
Position在下方有很大的雷
然后在上方
也就是说在6千9到6千6千9到7千
就是要冲破那个level
还是现在市场资金还是不足的
那么这个是相对来说比较悲观的
就相对来说有一些风险的这个看法
那么说些比较乐观的事情
就是乐观的话
我是觉得下天的话会有一些机会
就是特别是如果说真的跌的话
在哪里布局会更好
就是我们之前一直在讲
就是在AI时代
其实半导体的需求被改变
就是那个半导体被需求被改变
你们可以看GPU原来是打游戏的
它是一个很小市场
后来GPU变成了英伟达这样
那么英伟达现在当然不是做GPU的
英伟达现在做大型机的
但是在他做大型机等于做解决方案的时候
有很多的需求都会变得不同
确实我们以前觉得光和成储
有走到就是有点过头
就是长得有点过头
就估值有点贵
但是如果他调整也会有很好的机会
就是光和成储
确实是会有很好的机会
他如果调整的话
那个像美国的话已经调整到3007
调整到3007
如果是能够有更大的调整机会的话
因为这种调整并不是根据他这本面
这种调整有的时候
是根据市场去delayverage
包括对于韩国的那些三星海历史的调整
其实是到了到那个韩援的这个carriage band
然后整体韩国全部在去到暖性的咱卖出
所以这个中间是会有机会的
就在半导体上
第二个就是在CPU上
当然我们CPU的公司比较说
那个intel其实没有进入很大的调整
但是你们这样想
就是在建算力中心的时候是会需要光
然后甚至算力中心和算力中心对接
甚至会需要诺基亚
那是以前谁知道需要诺基亚这种东西
诺基亚的光
然后那个会需要光
会需要筒需要这些连接
以前的consumeratronic的干擾体系中间
没有这么大的需求
会需要存储
AI中间会需要存储
但是这个调用AI需要的是CPU
就是我之前一直觉得CPU的缺货是比较确定的
那对intel的这件事情有一些反思吧
也是我是本身是觉得intel
那经验的业绩很难实现
因为它的产能放在那里
然后但是问题是
CPU是直接跟AI调用相关的
明伟达自己有grace
有variable以后会有自己的芯片
varro会有自己的CPU芯片
但是他很多人在调用
或者是很多人在做AI方面的truining
其实他可能会需要一块
就上次我好像也说到
3月16号他可能会举风公布
他到时候可能会需要一块插Y6的芯片
所以这个是对intel是会有很大帮助
就是我们在看这个下跌的时候
并不是觉得美股会走路一个很大的熊市
或者是崩溃式的
他很快下调的时候会给市场投资
然后很多的机会去买路的机会
比较稳的比方说像那比例
英伟达
然后英伟达业绩确定性特别高
因为它是而且AI的
等于它是AI卖大铲子
但是铲子的配件也会有很多的机会
当它价位就是合适的时候
也就是说
最后它的主要的配件是GPU它自己做
CPU然后成熟光
这些都是它的配件
这个配件中间现在相对来说
没有被比较好炒的
肯定是光和存储
然后没有被很好定价的是CPU
所以我觉得在就是在那个
等一下
就是在如果市场有调整的机会的话
这个是if如果有调整机会的话
那么在这个三个方向
就是我觉得看那个调整程度大
我觉得是会有机会的
然后对于战争这件事情
我确实不是很专样
然后那个
是不是有可能战争真的在这里结束
那么这个是
一个很好愿景
就是我这个就给大家确定
我觉得是很好愿景
但是如果说上下风险博弈的话
我觉得现在风险相对来说
不是很对称
就是这么一个情况
然后我约内一下
看看大家
因为今天有点时间
看看大家有什么问题